[Musique]
qu'elle soit de jardin du pêcheur ou
encore perché dans les arbres les
cabanons de cesse de faire rêver les
petits et les grands
tout le monde en a moins fait une dans
sa vie que ce soit dans les désespace
intérieurs sous des couvertures ou sous
la table du salon avec la nappe qui
dépasse c'est une thématique que l'on
voit qui se développe aussi dans tout ce
qui est tourisme après plusieurs mois de
réflexion le palais du roi de Rome de
Rambouillet vous invite à découvrir son
exposition ouvrage cabane d'artistes
dessin ou encore maquette viennent
mettre à l'honneur cet abri insolite
cette oeuvre est une oeuvre d'Isabelle
Bond qui est une artiste contemporaine
qui s'appelle les trois amis elle expose
dans l'exposition 3 de ses créations et
donc ce qui est intéressant avec le
travail d'Isabelle bond c'est qu'elle
travaille les cabanes en miniature
principalement en fil de fer et utilise
également des matériaux naturels comme
ici de tarlatan de coton et puis voilà
ça ça permet de remettre l'homme une
petite échelle par rapport à la grandeur
de la nature c'est une exposition qui va
vraiment parler à tout le monde qui
développe plein de thématiques donc la
cabane d'architecte la cabane d'artistes
la cabane rituel la cabane et l'enfant
c'est les cabanes de métiers une
exposition aussi dédiée aux adeptes de
cachette dans l'imaginaire sera mis à
contribution ici dans cet espace ces
enfants peuvent créer leur propre cabane
donc on a mis à disposition différents
morceaux de tissus de couleur assez
neutres ainsi que des ainsi que des
coussins pour pouvoir aménager
l'intérieur et on propose également dans
la salle différents ouvrages que les
enfants peuvent lire plusieurs temps
forts sont prévus jusqu'à la fermeture
de l'exposition le 14 mai 2023 prochain
rendez-vous une visite avec un guide
conférencier le 26 mars